[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu
Tatort Deutschland eurem True Crime
Podcast mit Mirko kimir und der
wunderbaren Tony haer hallo auch von mir
und heute fangen wir mal etwas
ungewöhnlich an mit Musik kennt ihr
das
ja klar kennt ihr das und das ja
[Musik]
auch und natürlich den
hier
tolle Songs und definitiv Lieder die
ihre er definierten also wirklich
riesige Hits und wir müssen sie euch
leider ein bisschen vermiesen na ich sag
mal so die Songs bleiben natürlich
großartig und wichtig auch wenn der Mann
der hinter diesen drei und unzähligigen
weiteren hitsingel steht alles andere
als eine Lichtgestalt ist bzw war denn
er ist
verstorben
dem er seit 2009 wegen Mordes einsaß
Phil Spector Phil Spector genau also
eigentlich voll der coole Name klingt
ein bisschen wie so ein Bösewicht aus
einem James Bond Film ja aber es ist
kein Künstlername sondern der Name
unterdem er am 26 dezember 1939 in New
York geboren wird Harve Philip Phil
Spector schon früh begeistert er sich
für Musik als Teenager gründet er seine
eigene Band the teddy bears the teddy
bears das mal definitiv kein cooler Name
ja da hast du Recht aber damals in den
50ern da galten noch ganz andere
Konventionen für Bandnamen da hat sich
niemand mega death genannt oder Slayer
oder The Killers na ja Killers hätte ja
am Ende irgendwie noch Sinn ergeben aber
das wusste in den 50ern natürlich noch
niemand ein gemütlicher Teddybär war
Spector jedenfalls nie aber für
vielleicht sollten wir nicht so sie auf
dem Namen rumhacken die Teddybären
landen jedenfalls 1958 da ist Spector
gerade 19 mit to know him is to love him
eine Nummer 1 Hit viel Geld verdient das
Trio mit dem Song nicht das landet
nämlich bei der Plattenfirma und
vielleicht ist das ein Grund warum
spectter bald von der Bühne hinter die
Regler eines mischpuls wechselt und da
auch eine wahnsinnskarriere als
Songwriter und Produzentin liegt in den
frühen 1960er dann entwickelt er den
Wall of Sound eine ganz neue
Produktionstechnik bei der mit
orchesteruntermalung Effekten und dem
Kopieren und übereinanderlegen von
Gesangs und instrumentenspuren eine tja
klangmauer geschaffen wird die die
Zuhörer mit ihrer Wucht förmlich
erschlägt was den Sound anging war sein
großes Vorbild nicht die damalige
Popmusik sondern Richard Wagner ja das
passt dann wohl ganz gut und er selbst
nannte seine Produktionen ja auch
syfonien für Jugendliche Phil Spector
wird eine lebende Legende er führt die
runets zu ihrem mega Erfolg be my baby
den wir am Anfang schon kurz gehört
haben er arbeitet mit den Rolling Stones
den Beatles und später Solo mit George
Harrison Paul mcardney und John Lennon
mit Tina und Ike Turner River deep
Mountain high den haben wir am Anfang
auch kurz gehört mega Song und
tausendfach gecovert er arbeitet mit den
R und Leonard Cohen ist einfach
gigantisch erfolgreich wird in die Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame aufgenommen und
landet auf Platz 64 der Liste der 100
größten Musiker aller Zeiten des
popmagazins Rolling
[Musik]
Stone und dann am 3 februar 2003 gegen 5
Uhr morgens geht bei der Polizei in
Alhambra Kalifornien ein Notruf
ein
das ist filsb das Fahrer Adriano de sus
der vor spectors Anwesen gewartet hat er
habe einen Schuss gehört dann sei
Spector aus dem Haus gestürmt habe mit
einem Revolver herumgefuchtelt und ihm
zugerufen er habe woh jemanden
umgebracht
als die Polizei eintrifft findet sie die
Leiche einer großen blonden Frau getötet
von einem Schuss in den Mund und einen
aufgebrachten betrunkenen Phil Spector
den sie Tasern müssen um ihn wegen
Mordverdachts festnehmen zu
[Musik]
können die Tote ist Lana Clarkson
Schauspielerin in den a0ern ist sie eine
der ganz großen in der bmovie Szene man
könnte sagen dass sie für dieses Genre
beinah so stilprägend ist wie spekter
für die
Popmusik die Auftritte der
großgewachsenen durchtrainierten und
sehr attraktiven Frau in Film wie
Barbarian Queen Warrior King oder Amazon
woman of the moon sind legendär ja ich
muss zugeben mir sagen diese Titel
leider gar nichts aber das muss nichts
heißen na ja ist auch egal es sind wohl
eher keine oscarkandidaten gewesen und
nichts was das Prädikat besonders
wertvoll erhalten hätte aber hey Lana
hat hat Erfolg jede Menge Fans und sie
hat deutlich mehr drauf als sich leicht
bekleidet und schwertschwingt durch
Fantasy Filmsets zu metzeln vor allem in
Komödien kann sie zeigen was sie kann
allerdings überstrahlt ihre Rolle als
barbarenkönigin amtha alles andere in
den 90ern beginnt ihr Ruhm zu verblassen
sie ist jetzt über 30 und damals
bedeutet das leider für
Schauspielerinnen oft das Karriere aus
jup Typen kriegen Charakterrollen frauen
dürfen gehen na ja also zum Glück ändert
sich das langsam und es gibt eine ganze
Menge berühmter älterer sogar ja Alter
Schauspielerin die Sache mit dem
Karriereende die spielt in diesem Fall
doch noch aber eine wichtige Rolle
Werbung wir kriegen ja immer wieder
Fragen von euch rein was wir denn
eigentlich abgesehen von Podcasts machen
was wir so privat anstellen ob wir da
auch andere Interessensgebiete haben und
ich sag ganz klar nein in meiner
Freizeit verbringe ich gerne viel Zeit
von vom Fernseher irgendwie True Crime
Dokus kmmis etc ich bin ein ganz großer
Doku Fan und mag das halt wenn ich
irgendwie nach einem stressigen Tag nach
Hause komme oder aus dem Studio gehe und
dann am Abend irgendwie mich von einer
schönen Doku berieseln lasse oder sogar
ich geb es zu auch ein bisschen Trash TV
schaue bei mir ist das Problem bisschen
dass ich überhaupt gar keine richtigen
Sender habe das heißt ich kann halt
wirklich nur über Apps oder Mediatheken
gucken und wenn ich halt so richtig
Fernsehprogramm will muss ich halt zu
meiner Tante rüber an die Wohnung bei
mir ist das eigentlich ich habe einen
Fernseher zum Glück ja ich muss nicht zu
meiner Tante oder zu meinem Onkel gehen
ich habe einen Fernseher auch so richtig
mit Sendern so richtig mit Sendern bei
mir ist halt nur das Problem dass es
dann manchmal Streit was heißt Streit
aber dann gibt's halt manchmal
Diskussion darüber was man denn gerade
sehen will ja der eine möchte das der
andere das und so geht es hin und her
also der berühmte Streit um die
Fernbedienung genau den könnt ihr euch
aber ersparen denn mit o2 TV könnt ihr
ganz einfach übers Internet schauen da
findet ihr über 130 TV-Sender in HD und
ihr könnt auch bis zu 100 Stunden an
live Sendungen Serien und so weiter
einfach aufnehmen oder Filme anhalten
und später weiterschauen und das gute
ist MKO ihr müsst euch nicht mehr
prügeln was ihr gucken wollt denn mit o2
TV funktionieren bis zu vier
unterschiedliche Geräte gleichzeitig und
das nicht nur zu Hause sondern auch
unterwegs und das beste o2 t gibt es
jetzt sogar inklusive Netflix das ist
natürlich ein super Angebot denn ich bin
ja ein riesengroßer Rick und Morty Fan
und auch the office das sind beide
Serien die bei mir meiner Netflix watch
list ganz ganz oben stehen ich werde
immer in meinem Freundeskreis ein
bisschen gehänselt dass ich noch nie
diese US-Serie shameless gesehen habe
die gab's aber bisher noch nicht auf
Netflix seit dem 1 September haben sie
alle Staffeln drauf geballert und das
sage ich dir am nächsten Wochenende wird
da richtig durchgesuchtet also falls ihr
die Serie auch noch nicht kennt es ist
eure Chance guck GCK euch mal unbedingt
an also Bucht jetzt o2 TV für günstige
9,99 € im Monat undterhaltet 12 Monate
Netflix geschenkt geht dafür einfach auf
o2de/got/atort also
o2.de/g/ Tatort t a t o r t und sichert
euch mit o2 TV und Netflix das Beste aus
live Fernsehen und Streaming als Paket
alle
und den link zum Angebot den findet ihr
auch in unseren Show nototes und ihr
wisst ja Leute o2 can
do Werbung Ende Anfang 2003 arbeitet
Lana Clarkson im House of Blues einem
Restaurant und Veranstaltungsort in West
Hollywood am 3 Februar versucht jemand
sich in einen für eine private Feier
abgesperrten Teil des Restaurants zu
schleichen Clarkson hält die Person auf
sie können dort nicht inin m sagt sie
denn sie glaubt das mit einer Frau zu
tun zu haben ein Kollege klärt sie auf
dass sei Phils Bor der sei Gold für den
Club der dürfte überall hin der Name
sagt Lana nichts aber sie entschuldigt
sich tut mir leid misspter autch ja das
muss weh getan haben denn dieser Mann
fand es ganz sicher nicht lustig dass
ihn jemand für eine Frau hält das werden
wir später noch sehen aber erstmal
verzeiht erana den und er lädt Sie ein
nach der Arbeit soll sie doch einfach zu
ihm kommen auf sein Anwesen sein Castle
sein Schloss wie er es nennt und das ist
keine Übertreibung Lana zeigt anfangs
wenig Lust mitzugehen aber vi Spector
ist niemand der ein Nein akzeptiert
irgendwann willigt Lana schließlich ein
auf einen Drink mit zu ihm zu kommen und
Adriano de Susa fährt die beiden zu
vielpector Kassel eine gute Stunde
später fällt ein Schuss Lana Clarkson
ist
tot was geschieht in dieser einen Stunde
und vor allem in den letzten Sekunden
ein Unfall sagt Phils Spector ein
versehentlicher Selbstmord später
korrigiert er diese Aussage es sei ein
bewusster Selbstmord gewesen eine Frau
die ihrem vergangenen Ruh nachtrauerte
habe sich im Haus des berühmten filzbor
getötet um etwas von seinem zu erhaschen
ja und dass sie tot ist das scheint ihn
wenig zu kümmern er betrachtet es eher
als affr gegen ihn wie kann diese
[__] es wagen beschwert er sich bei
den Beamten ja cooler Typ im Sinne von
absolut gar kein cooler Typ Phil Spector
der Mann der so viele unsterbliche
Liebeslieder geschrieben und unter
anderem auch produziert hat der
verachtet Frauen und weil er nicht ohne
sie leben kann versucht er sie zu
kontrollieren und klein zu halten ein
Beispiel ist seine Beziehung zu Veronica
Bennett freundfrau der ronets die beiden
führen eine jahrelange Beziehung ohne
dass Veronica ahnt dass Bor bereits
verheiratet ist er selbst ist dagegen
extrem
eifersüchtig 1966 Touren die ronets mit
den Beatles durch die USA sie sind auf
dem Höhepunkt ihres Ruhmes und Veronica
ist nicht dabei ihre Cousine muss für
sie einspringen weil pH ihr verboten hat
mit den Beatles auf Tour zu gehen er
vermutet dass John Lennon etwas von ihr
will 1968 heiraten Veronica und Phil und
sein Kontrollwahn nimmt immer schlimmere
Züge an er sperrt sie praktisch ein es
gibt die Geschichte also wir können sie
nicht mit hundertprozentiger Sicherheit
bestätigen aber es gibt diese Geschichte
dass Veronica nur dann allein zum
Shoppen in die Stadt fahren durfte wenn
auf Ihrem Beifahrersitz eine
aufblaspuppe sitzt die als filsb
verkleidet ist na ja also exzentrisch
war der Mann ohne Frage und eifersüchtig
wahnsinnig eifersüchtig und
kontrollierend ja es gibt auf jeden Fall
eine Menge gruseliger Geschichten über
seinen Umgang mit Frauen aber die machen
ihn natürlich noch nicht z Mörder und
tatsächlich deutet einiges darauf hin
dass Lana Clarkson sich selbst den
Revolver in den Mund gesteckt und
abgedrückt hat Spector so sagte er es
aus sei aus dem Raum gegangen und als er
zurückkam habe er den Selbstmord nicht
mehr verhindern können er habe etwa 3 m
von ihr entfernt gestanden als es
passierte ja aber da sind einige
Ungereimtheiten vor allem die Aussage
seines Fahrers also das Spector selbst
gesagt habe er habe vermutlich jemanden
umgebracht im Prozess der erst im Jahr
2007 beginnt Spector bleibt in den
Jahren dazwischen gegen Kaution auf
freiem Fuß wird dieser Aussage eine
zentrale Rolle spielen und vor allem der
Verteidigung helfen denn es gelingt ihr
die Glaubwürdigkeit des zeugenen Frage
zuellen des Susa stammt aus Brasilien
seine Muttersprache ist also
Portugiesisch da sei es ja wohl sehr
leicht etwas
misszuverstehen das zweite wichtige
Argument der Verteidigung ist das Leben
von Lana cllarksen Spector habe kein
Motiv gehabt sie zu töten Lana cllarksen
hingegen so stellen die Anwälte es da
jeden Grund sich umzubringen ihr Stern
war dabei zu sinken sie musste in einem
arbeiten um über die Runden zu kommen
und konnte nicht hoffen noch einmal als
barbarenkönigin auf die Leinwand zu
kommen außerdem taucht ein Schriftstück
auf das ihre tiefe Depression belegt ja
und das ist ein Text den sie in ihren
Teenagerjahren geschrieben hatte also
mehr als 20 Jahre vor ihrem angeblichen
Selbstmord aber die Verteidigung greift
nach jedem strohheim denn die Anklage
die hat viel bessere Argumente
aufzubringen da sind zum ein die harten
Fakten Spector behauptet mehr als 3 m
vor Lana zu stehen als der Schussfeld
doch an seiner Kleidung werden kleine
Blutspritzer gefunden die ihn dort nicht
hätten treffen können an der Waffe
werden keine Fingerabdrücke von ihm
gefunden allerdings auch nicht von Lana
stattdessen findet man ein Tuch wie es
zum Reinigen von Waffen verwendet wird
und das im Bart von Phils vector und
daran sind Blutspuren des Opfers die
Waffe wurde also gereinigt und das ganz
sicher nicht von Lana Clarkson in einem
Schrank im Obergeschoss des Hauses
finden die Ermittler eine Jacke von
Spector an der ebenfalls kleine
Blutspuren sind nicht gerade ein
übliches Verhalten nachdem man Zeuge
eines Selbstmordes wurde erst einmal
nach oben zu gehen und die Jacke in den
Schrank zu
hängen komisch ist auch dass Lana
Clarkson ihre Handtasche über der
Schulter hat als sie tot aufgefunden
wird wenn spectors Aussage stimmt dann
muss sie als er kurz den Raum verlassen
hat beschlossen haben sich zu töten
dann eine Waffe gesucht und gefunden
haben sich ihre Handtasche umgehängt
sich hingesetzt und dann erschossen
haben h ja na ja apropos Waffe ich
glaube wir haben noch nicht über
spectors Verhältnis zu Waffen berichtet
das spielt für die Anklage nämlich auch
eine große Rolle Spector ist ein
waffenah und nah ist hier ganz wörklich
zu verstehen ja verrückter würde es noch
besser treffen er hat immer eine Waffe
dabei und er benutzt sie Leonard Cohen
berichtet von einer Aufnahmesession im
Studio die er abbrechen will weil er
sich unwohl fühlt Spector zieht sein
Revolver und richtet ihn auf den Musiker
du bleibst bis wir hier fertig sind
Cohen bleibt viele Musikerinnen und
Musiker berichten ähnliches bei einer
Gelegenheit schießt der sogar in die
studiodecke sicher hat er nicht vor
jemanden zu töten aber als Scherze kann
man diese Vorfälle auch nicht abtun
spekor will
einschüchtern vor allem die Frauen im
Prozess kommen mehrere Frauen zu Wort
die bezeugen dass er sie mit einer Waffe
bedroht hat meist wenn sie ihn verlassen
wollten oder sich ihm verweigerten
wollte Lin Clarkson wirklich wie sie es
angekündigt hatte nach einem Drink gehen
wollte spekor mehr und konnte die
Zurückweisung nicht ertragen ein
weiterer Zeuge sagt aus Phil Spector
habe ihm einmal erklärt warum er immer
eine Waffe dabei habe wegen der Frauen
die hätten nämlich alle eine Kugel in
den Kopf verdient der Prozess gegen
philspector endet im September 2007 ohne
Ergebnis das ist so krass
einfach okay also es ist der
Verteidigung gelungen die
Glaubwürdigkeit des Fahrers fragwürdig
erscheinen zu lassen und das Opfer als
heruntergekomme depressive lebensmüde
Frau ohne Hoffnung darzustellen was sie
nicht war klar ist sie zum Zeitpunkt
ihres Todes nicht mehr die berühmte
bewunderte barbarenkönigin und arbeitet
in einem Nachtclub aber sie hat Träume
und Pläne sie arbeitet an einem
standupprramm um endlich ihr komisches
Talent voll
auszuspielen nichts bis auf diesen mehr
als 20 Jahre alten Brief deutet auf eine
Frau hin die so verzweifelt ist dass sie
sich in einem Fremden Haus das Leben
nehmen würde ja aber bei der Jury
verfängt die Geschichte trotz aller
anderen Indizien der Prozess platzt weil
sich die Jury nicht auf ein einstimmiges
Urteil einigen kann in einer zweiten
Verhandlung 2008 bis 2009 wird Spektor
schließlich des Mordes zweiten Grades
schuldig gesprochen das liegt im
deutschen Strafgesetzbuch irgendwo
zwischen Mord und Totschlag
2021 stirbt Phil Spector 81-jährig im
Gefängnis ja und mit ihm der einzige der
die ganze Wahrheit über diese
schreckliche Nacht im Jahr 2003 hätte
verkünden können wollte Spektor Lana
cllarksen einschüchtern wieso viele
Frauen vor ihr hat sich dabei
versehentlich ein Schuss gelöst oder hat
er sogar an irgendeinem Punkt
beschlossen sie zu töten klar ist nur
eins diese Geschichte vom Selbstmord die
kann so wie Spector sie darstellte nicht
stimmen und damit sind wir am Ende
unserer heutigen Geschichte und unserem
Ausflug in die Musikgeschichte für
unsere heutige Ausgabe haben wir Artikel
von BC News Welt de Laar CNN und BBC
verwendet außerdem Episoden der
amerikanischen Podcasts Hollywood crime
scene dark Hollywood und the Generation
Y Podcast danke fürs zuhören und bis zum
nächsten mal eure Tony und euer
Mirko